i think from what i know and at the
moment it's like a mill a month
that that would put you at the hot that
would put you at the very highest uh
echelon this is belle del fin in 2019
she made over 10 million dollars selling
her own bath water she also made an
estimated 1.2 million dollars per month
on only fans but while she's loved by
many on the internet she wasn't always
this popular bell delphine was
relentlessly bullied at school and
received online abuse after using social
media as an outlet she uploaded a photo
that would go on to change her life she
became one of the most talked about
online personalities on the internet
then she vanished beldelphine's journey
is an unlikely story of a marketing
genius
this is how she went from school dropout
to internet personality to making
millions online
she was born on october 23 1999. she
grew up in cape town south africa where
she was raised in a devout christian
household after her parents divorced she
and her mother moved to england she was
a weird kid growing up in her
adolescence she was an avid watcher of
the anti-political correctness genre of
youtubers like idubbbz and filthy frank
at school beldelphine was relentlessly
bullied and received online abuse her
classmates found videos of her making
offensive jokes in the styles of her
favorite youtubers and was sharing
screenshots of the clips ramping up the
bullying she would apparently wake up to
hate comments every single day she felt
isolated from her classmates due to her
dark sense of humor bel delphine
suffered from depression and dropped out
of school at the age of 14. it became a
turning point in her life
beldelphine was a hustler from a young
age she worked as a waitress and barista
she began to use social media as an
outlet for her creativity experimenting
with looks costumes and aesthetics
it was the only place where people
actually accepted her
on the 27th of march 2015 she posted her
first ever instagram picture she
uploaded a makeup tutorial as her first
youtube video in august 2016. in 2018
bel delphine began to regularly upload
pictures of her modeling on instagram
using accessories such as pink wigs fly
high stockings and cat ears to help
create what she described as weird elf
kitty girl aesthetic
she also regularly produced cosplay
related content which included
characters such as harley quinn from dc
comics as well as diva from overwatch in
march 2018 bel delphine launched her
patreon account and posted lewd content
where users would have to donate to gain
access to her locked posts and private
snapchat
within the next eight months the page
accumulated upwards of more than one
thousand patrons
as she started to gain attention online
beldelphine uploaded a photo that would
go on to change her life on september 10
2018 beldolphine posted the now infamous
picture of herself wearing elfies while
making an ahigao face on instagram the
face is an exaggerated facial expression
of characters in japanese manga
her post went viral over the next two
months it received more than 35 000
likes and marked the beginning of her
internet fame on september 21st 2018 a
subreddit was created for fans of bel
delphine within a month the community
gained over 22 000 subscribers
on february 4th 2019 youtuber will n e
uploaded a video titled i spent 2 500
on beldelphine's patreon
showing footage of himself purchasing a
high tier reward on bell delphine's
patreon page which garnered more than 7
million views and 23 000 comments in one
month
in the same month youtuber pyro cynical
uploaded a video titled i paid bel
delphine three thousand dollars to be my
girlfriend within two weeks the video
received upwards of 2.3 million views
and 16 000 comments
on june 14 2019 bel delphine uploaded a
video titled meet my best friend in
which she performs various activities
with a dead octopus wearing googly eyes
within two months the video accumulated
upwards of 4.3 million views and 52 000
comments in the same month bel delphine
made a post on her instagram account
promising to create a pornhub account if
the post got a million likes
the post gained over 1.8 million likes
in just five days
beldelphian created a pornhub account
she uploaded a total of 12 videos all of
which were non-pornographic troll videos
with provoking titles one of her other
videos titled pewdiepie goes all the way
inside bel delphine was a minute long
clip that showed her eating a picture of
youtuber pewdiepie pornhub's annual
statistics report listed beldelphine as
the most searched celebrity in 2019
[Music]
on july 1 2019 beldelphine launched her
online store selling bell delphine
themed merchandise including mousepads
posters and a product dubbed gamergirl
bathwater the product was marketed as
the remains of her bath water in a jar
and was priced at thirty dollars each
the first batch of the bath water sold
out in just three days and she made over
a million dollars the product was met
with controversy media coverage and
internet memes rumors began to spread
online that 50 or more people had
contracted herpes from the product but
it was proven to be a hoax
youtube response videos also sprung up
featuring individuals supposedly
drinking cooking and vaping her bath
water beldelphine continued using her
patreon and twitter accounts at one
point her patreon account had over four
thousand supporters
polygon noted that at least one man
spent twenty five hundred dollars in
exchange for a personal skype
conversation with delphine on october
7th 2019 beldelphine tweeted an image of
her mugshot with a caption detailing
that she was arrested
the image contained a metropolitan
police service watermark although there
were no external proof of an arrest from
the metropolitan police or otherwise
beldelfin stated that someone had stolen
her pet hamster at a party and she
vandalized the thief's car in
retaliation resulting in her arrest
online publications and users questioned
the authenticity of her claims while the
metropolitan police stated they were
unable to disclose any information
regarding the arrest due to the data
protection act after that incident she
vanished and disappeared from the
internet
[Music]
nearly a year later in june 2020
beldelfin returned to social media with
a youtube music video the video promoted
her newly launched instagram tick tock
and only fans accounts around this time
bell delphine started posting adult and
explicit content on her twitter account
her only fans account gained a huge
following on november 27th 2020 bell
delphine posted on twitter and teased
the release of an adult video at the end
of the year
on christmas day she uploaded her first
adult video to her only fans account
business insider reported that her only
fans account was drawing in over 1.2
million dollars per month
after the release of her adult video she
disappeared again and she hasn't been
active on social media since 2021 though
her only fans account is still active
[Music]
no one really knows what she's up to
nowadays and her disappearance has once
again got people talking but it's not
the first time she's vanished and most
people speculate that she's once again
using her disappearance to generate
media hype for her return
there's no doubt she's a weird character
her online persona has garnered a huge
amount of attention and she's become a
viral sensation with her very own army
of simps
she's also made millions from her
internet fame and achieved great
financial success along the way
[Music]
from being bullied online to making
millions online what can we learn from
bel delphine's journey to success
she influenced millions and made
millions
people often care too much about what
others might think of them beldelphine
found success because she eventually
stopped caring about what others thought
of her and decided to pursue an online
career she's often criticized due to her
provocative and controversial content
behind her weird online persona she's
actually a brilliant marketer a quote
from renowned marketer seth godin you're
either remarkable or invisible make a
choice beldelphine didn't receive much
attention when she just posted makeup
tutorials and cosplay pictures
she couldn't stand out because there
were already a ton of content creators
who posted the same content to stand out
she had to do something different the
weird facial expressions as well as the
dead octopus were in googly eyes garnet
a huge amount of attention and big
youtubers started to do response videos
this helped her go viral and led to her
gaining millions of followers on social
media she then monetized that audience
by selling her gamer girl bathwater a
weird product that gave her even more
attention on social media and by
cleverly staging disappearances she was
able to create mystery and intrigue to
generate media hype for her eventual
return and she profited massively from
her only fans account she came she saw
she conquered the world of simps
behind her weird online persona is she a
business savvy entrepreneur or did she
just take advantage of her fans the
comment section in this one will be very
interesting
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one